the only way that you can bear to be
around your friends is to drink you need
better friends
and if the only sort of people that want
you to be friends with them are when
you're destroying your health along with
them then you definitely need benefit
alcohol is the only drug where if you
don't do it people assume you have a
problem no one says dude why are you why
are you not taking heroin this evening
like have you not do you not fancy
smacking up tonight do we not are we not
are we not going to get like blazed out
of our mouth like no one says that right
it's alcohol alcohol has a cultural
position that is completely different to
Every Other Drug and
most people I think have it in the back
of their mind that they probably would
be a bit of a better person if they took
a break from drinking and people can get
pretty upset when you start to throw
into harsh contrast the errors and
lapses that they know that they're
making on a daily basis